another big story this morning USA
Gymnastics is filing for bankruptcy
protection as it faces about 100
lawsuits over its handling of the Larry
Nasser sex abuse scandal the governing
body for American gymnastics says
bankruptcy will help resolve the
lawsuits but a victim's attorney says
that it's just a delaying tactic Nasir
was sentenced to prison for the rest of
his life CBS this morning Saturday
co-host Dana Jacobson shows us how one
prominent critic says the organization's
problems extend well beyond this
bankruptcy issue Dana good morning good
morning USA Gymnastics says that
bankruptcy filing is not a liquidation
but a reorganization to help move the
organization and a sport forward but a
former USA Gymnastics board member and
NASA whistleblower says USA Gymnastics
is no closer to protecting what matters
most its athletes still reeling from the
Larry Nasser sexual abuse scandal USA
Gymnastics filed for chapter 11
bankruptcy as it faces 100 lawsuits from
over 350 athletes in a statement the
organization says the filing will help
resolve claims made by Nasser's sexual
abuse survivors calling it a critical
first step in rebuilding the community's
trust I don't see how anybody can trust
that organization to run you know the
sport of gymnastics Jessica Howard is a
former team USA gymnast and board member
I trusted USA gymnastics but I was
sexually abused as were so many other
athletes she was among the first
gymnasts to speak out against NASA in
2016
saying she too was a victim to USA
gymnastics has made absolutely no
changes that have affected victims
survivors the filing would stop all 100
lawsuits from proceeding including a
complaint by the US Olympic Committee
that seeks to revoke USA Gymnastics
status as a national governing body make
no mistake this is an American tragedy
attorney John manly whose firm
represents more than 180 of Nasser's
victims called bankruptcy a delay tactic
in addressing sexual abuse claims Howard
says the organization isn't capable of
protecting the athletes I don't think
the sport will survive at the highest
levels
if we don't get this right Wednesday's
filing comes as USA Gymnastics continue
to search for a new CEO lawsuits are
estimated to cost the Federation as much
as 150 million dollars now back in May
Michigan State University where NASA
also worked announced a five hundred
million dollar settlement with more than
300 victims USA Gymnastics says the
bankruptcy filing does not affect the
amount of money available to victims
which they say is funded by insurance
Nora
all right Jana thank you